those investors who sold stocks just
before the stock market crashed in 1929
were either wise or exceptional lucky
and maybe we have no error
so even when i read that what felt
really awkward was saying wise or
exceptional lucky this exceptional felt
really strange because it's trying to
it's trying to it's trying to modify the
lucky it's trying to tell us well what
type of lucky we were we were not
exceptional lucky this is an adverb an
adverb we should say this we were
exceptionally
exceptionally lucky so the error right
over here is in d we don't need just an
adjective we need an adverb we are we
are modifying another adjective we're
modifying lucky what type of lucky we
were we were exceptionally
lucky so the error is in part d